ein kraftwerk das durch eine kernfusion
unmengen an energie produziert das
könnte die lösung aller energieprobleme
dieser erde sein das große vorbild die
sonne
der traum vom forschungsteams weltweit
das kernfusion sex parlament wendelstein
7-x bei greifswald ist ein heißer
kandidat um neue spannende erkenntnisse
dazu zu liefern nach umbauarbeiten denen
die experimente jetzt in die heiße phase
welche experimente genau in der
versuchsanlage geplant sind und wie
realistisch kernfusion den kraftwerken
in naher zukunft sind jetzt in klicks
und science fiction herzlich willkommen
ja fast anderthalb jahre war es nun
ruhig um das kernfusion sex peri mend
wendelstein 7-x bei greifswald nach
einer riesigen menge umbauarbeiten gegen
die experimente aber in diesem monat
september 2017 wieder los und zwar mit
vollgas in die entscheidende phase
fusions relevante plasmen mit einer
heizleistung von acht megawatt sollen
erzeugt werden tatsächlich doppelt so
viel wie bisher das plasma wird dabei
unvorstellbare 70 millionen grad celsius
heiß und soll nach den vorstellungen des
kreis walter forschungsteams zehn
sekunden lang stabil bleiben und hat
diesen bedingungen wollen wir plasmen
erzeugen die näher an die zustände
rücken unter denen in der sonne energie
aus der kernfusion von wasserstoff
klassen gewonnen wird was erklärt
institutsdirektor thomas klinger und
diese pläne sind tatsächlich realistisch
wendelstein 7-x gilt als eine der
modernsten forschungsanlagen in diesem
bereich der reaktor bei greifswald in
der vergangenheit schon mehr als
erfolgreich ende 2015 haben wir darüber
berichtet hatte das institut mit der
kernfusion anlage das erste plasma
erzeugt mehr als 1000 die experimente
folgten und elektronen temperaturen von
bis zu 100 millionen grad celsius und
ionen temperaturen von bis zu 20
millionen grad überzeugten dann am ende
auch den letzten kritiker und jetzt
haben die techniker und technikerinnen
den reaktor in den letzten monaten enorm
aufgerüstet mit einer leistungsfähigeren
heizung messinstrumenten und einem
hitzeschild unter anderem haben sie
spezielle prall platten auf grafit
montieren so genannte die welt touren
damit will das forschungsteam die
leistung der mikrowellen heizung auf 8,5
megawatt verdoppeln und eine höhere
dichte und temperatur des glas was
erzählen auch die sicherheitssteuerung
wurden überarbeitet genauso wie die
magnetfelder damit das passt mal optimal
eingeschlossen werden kann dermaßen
aufgerüstet könnte wendelstein 7-x im
dauerbetrieb funktionieren und so
vielleicht sogar den puls betriebene
fusions typ druckermarkt hinter sich
lassen und die geplanten experimente
sind wirklich mehr als spannend mehr als
100 forscherinnen und forscher aus dem
ausland haben vorschläge eingereicht und
sich qualifiziert verschiedene
themenbereiche sollen erforscht werden
unter anderem aspekte zur stabilität des
plasmas zum einschluss des plasmas in
den magnet ring und auch zur heizung
nach diesem ersten meilenstein sind dann
weitere umbauten geplant um in etwa drei
jahren klassen für eine dauer von einer
halben stunde aufzubauen das wäre
wirklich ein riesiger schritt dafür soll
die heizleistung langfristig um weitere
2 megawatt erhöht werden unter anderem
durch kohlenstofffaserverstärkte
kunststoff elemente die die bislang
vorhandenen graphit kacheln ersetzen
sollen die große frage die im
versuchsreaktor beantwortet werden soll
wie kraftwerks tauglich ist das design
der anlagen des typs der laudator
hierbei wird das plasma von einem
kompliziert verwobenen magnetfeld von
den wänden ferngehalten
die ergebnisse sollen forschungsteams
weltweit dann bei ihren plänen weiter
helfen langfristig ein kraftwerk zu
entwickeln indem letztendlich
elektrischer strom gewonnen wird denn
das ist das ziel von wenn stein 7x ist
sollen alle vorarbeiten für den bau
eines kraftwerks dieses generator typs
geleistet werden und es scheint als
läuft hier wirklich alles nach plan
wir haben ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet die sonne ist das natürliche
vorbild für die kernfusion hierbei
verschmelzen die atomkerne von
wasserstoff und der sehr hohem druck und
hoher temperatur miteinander
dabei entsteht helium und riesige mengen
an
unsere zwei gesetzt deswegen wird die
kernfusion auch als die neue primäre
energiequelle gehandelt und könnte
tatsächlich co2 frei erneuerbare
energien ergänzen und ist dabei vor
allem viel ungefährlicher als die
aktuelle atom spaltung in
kernkraftwerken
hier kann es zu einer super gefährlichen
kettenreaktionen kommen die unmengen an
radioaktiver strahlung freisetzt bei
einem fusionsreaktor kommt die reaktion
beim unfall dagegen einfach zum erliegen
und die radioaktiven stoffe die
entstehen besitzen eine halbwertszeit
von jahrzehnten und nicht von
jahrmillionen die kernfusion wäre ein
riesenfortschritt hier bei pixum halte
ich das natürlich dazu auf dem laufen
wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit die kernfusion
wird realität wenn stein 7x hier geht es
um das erste plasma das in greifswald
erzeugt wurde mit noch mehr
hintergrundinfos also nicht verpassen
und draufklicken viel spaß dabei und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran